other guy here all right we got this
couple man woman right what does society
like what do we need for society to work
we need a house we might need the
internet right I mean we don't we don't
need it but we all you know we need a
car hypothetically we live in like I
know I can't draw I can't draw so just
you know bear with me we need
electricity we need plumbing and what
percent of women do these jobs so it's
roughly 90 plus percent of men are
building the houses they're building the
cars they're doing the electricity
they're doing the plumbing I can't
really think of one job where women
dominate in that we need now this is
what they'll tell me right like I got
some I got some hater shock they'll say
well women work at the DMV women are
teachers and health care now here's
here's the problem all of these jobs men
could easily learn